des débuts difficiles de matthieu
delormeau regardez c'est une sorte de
sous l'habile ah non il va être
extrêmement langue de bois
sap a été quelqu'un de sympa avec moi
j'y crois pas une seconde si le centre
aéré je pense qu'il en avait marre c'est
pas quelqu'un qui disait bonjour
facilement je pense ce garçon manque de
recul et second degré justement été
complètement fermée à nrj12 en faisant
des choses très médiocre ça fait sept
ans tu me vends des programmes de merde
qui me pourrissent la vie je veux dire
donc me retrouver avec lui là
franchement excusez moi mais ça me
gonfle globalement je crois je m'en fous
un peu
j'ai appris avec le temps de pommes
m'attacher aux nouveaux c'était le début
du sit in de mathieu larocque est ce que
vous pensez toujours ce que vous avez
dit et je regrette pas ce que j'ai
appris à aimer ses défauts en fait non
c'est vrai mais oui oui les émissions
dans les émissions qui produit à part
les dogues c'est vachement bien mais on
n'est pas là pour faire voilà bah ouais
sinon voila mais sinon franchement dans
le meck agathe vous vous entendez mieux
que matthieu delormeau
on rigole bien je crois dans la cour de
récré ou encore d'être aimable
je rends compte qu'être quelque chose
c'est évidemment déjà à l'époque tu
étais quand même un peu vicieux et airs
entraînants halage exige qu'on va pas
cyril c'est la première c'est un peu je
me vois pas sur le conducteur à être
présents quoi tu me dis bébé parce que
faut pas le dire ou de tous âges pas les
vexer thema star c'est vrai service
comme tu es ma star c'est une vraie
arrivée que tu fais signer pro d2 en
retard je te jure
une arrivée des couches tu le dis et du
coup ce que je vais faire je laisse les
autres et après tu ne tarissent pas en
même temps que les autres tarifs après
était ça l'a vraiment tu vois et après
tu as vu qu'elle a rejetées les stars et
moi j'étais tout content et en fait
c'est moi ce que tu avais réservé cette
espèce de séquences et pas du tout parce
que tu voulais que tu arrives après
c'est normal
oui mais c'est pas comme elle en a vendu
donc doute bien vendu en disant tu sais
quoi tu va s'arrêter pendant 50 minutes
et puis après mon chéri chez toi qu'ils
allaient fracassés comme ça bonjour la
part lui a nui va'a par lui au plus tout
le monde était plutôt sympa
il n'a pas eu un actif les autres quoi
type les hommes majeurs s'est dit que
j'étais content que tout arrive et avec
olivier chiabodo serra